cette maison de l'europe
elle fait de l'information de la
formation et l anime du débat sur
l'ensemble des questions européennes
en fait elle vise à faire vivre l'europe
sur le territoire de bourgogne franche
comté à travers divers types d'activités
en direction de différents publics
il ya beaucoup d'enseignants il ya des
adultes qui ont des questions à nous
poser sur différents sujets ça peut
aller effectivement pas parfois de
questions qui sont liées à des voyages
ou à des à la découverte de certains
pays jusque voilà des questions plus
particulière autour du budget en ce
moment on a beaucoup de questions sur
comment fonctionne l'union européenne
que fait le parlement à quoi ça sert
comment travail des députés européens
donc plein de questions voilà que chaque
citoyen peut venir nous poser puis
effectivement on a quand même aussi un
public jeune très important à la maison
de l'europe l'europe tour c'est un
projet qui permet à la maison de
l'europe en fait de sillonner la
bourgogne franche comté et de faire des
étapes soit dans des établissements
collèges lycées dans l'ensemble de la
grande région soit par exemple sur des
places publiques ou dans des villes où
pour soutenir
je sais pas l'organisation d'une
manifestation à d'un jumelage
alors l'europe tour c'est du 29 avril
jusqu'au 28 mai 26 étapes dans toute la
région bourgogne franche comté